yeah listen I'm on it
and we can close this taxi do you have
any experience of caregiving um I've
never done it but I'm sure I could learn
then that's gonna be well well this is
your music lark
Nathan will talk you through world's
routines and equipment I don't know if
it'll cross me mother my brain isn't
paralyzed yet
hi what am I here for to cheer him up I
guess so I thought we could go out this
afternoon my mother says you're chatty
can we strike a deal whereby you are
very unchic around me he hates me every
time I speak he looks to me like I'm
stupid to be fair you are pretty stupid
yeah but he doesn't know that yeah
interesting choice of footwear what do
you mean by that I can't be from around
here this is the kind of place people
come to and they got tired of actually
living I'm happy yeah well you shouldn't
be they get one life it's actually your
duty to live it as fully as possible
well can I ask you something let's just
bet you're going to sorry I'm being
trustee again no stay tell me something
good when I was little my favorite
outfit was my bumblebee tights bumblebee
to be honest right Oh Pig [ __ ] you ever
love anything that much yes loving can
hurt loving you a bit of an action man
before happening oh but if we got your
own really good fitness Reggie okay it's
fine
truth is I thought I could crack this
and then go back as if nothing had
changed that was wrong
can I take you somewhere you're so going
on a date with will trainers we get the
red dress out keep this look I don't
wanna go in yet I just want to be a man
who's been to a concert the girl in the
red dress a few minutes well loving can
hear you it is four thousand two years
the last one nearly killed him I
promised my parents six months that's
what I've given them what happens before
me I want him to lose but only if he
wants to leave I thought that this
happened you can't change her people are
mean what can you do you love them you
take care of him he's a good one I don't
want you to miss all the things that
someone else could give you
I have become a whole new person because
of you
can i something call you up pretty much
there anything that makes me want to get
up in the morning wait for me to come
home is climb ha ha
can we please fly Dominic that's my man
a homage to enforcer for most enforcers
that's a capability viscosity service
typically